[Music]
Sadiq Khan the mayor of London has made
some powerful opponents he doesn't know
me never met me doesn't know what I'm
all about
I think they're very rude statements and
frankly tell him I will remember those
debuts my message to Donald Trump and
his team is that you know your views of
Islam are ignorant he's the first Muslim
mayor of a major Western capital and
proud of it this is how Sadiq Khan went
from the son of Pakistani immigrants to
a lawyer lawmaker and now the Mayor of
London Khan's parents emigrated from
Pakistan his father was a bus driver his
mother a stay-at-home seamstress the 10
strong Khan family squeezed into a
three-bedroom flat in South London he
wanted to be a dentist but TV in the
1980s convinced him otherwise objection
LA law with its Swagger and ill-fitting
suits court kansai he graduated in 1991
with a degree in law from North London
University and joined a human rights
firm Khan worked a number of
high-profile cases often clashing with
London's Metropolitan Police Force but
he had bigger political ambitions this
is what being a new MP is like squatting
on a bench in the absence of an office
dealing with letters from constituents
reports are just coming in of an
explosion here in London only two months
after Khan entered the Commons as a
Member of Parliament London was attacked
by Islamist extremists that they will
stay with me for the rest of my life he
spoke out against the attacks both as a
London MP and as a Muslim he has been
very clear about his opposition to
violence opposition to terrorism and has
set out to make the case for a more a
more open and peaceful Islam that's
Thomas Penney one of Bloomberg's
Westminster correspondents here is a man
who is a Muslim and he is standing up
and being open and straightforward and
being clear that the problem here is not
Islam but Islamic extremism in 2015 a
decade after the attacks Khan ran for
mayor of London and his face was back in
the headlines his opponent Zac Goldsmith
trying to link Khan to radical Islam the
debate got again personal and nasty the
Goldsmith camp is called parn extreme
and accused him of associating with
quote those who seek to do our police
and capital ah even the former Prime
Minister David Cameron repeated the
allegations he shared a platform with
Sergio Shaheed the man who trained the
ringleader of the 7/7 attacks and
accused the United States are bringing
9/11 on themselves but the smears didn't
stick that Goldsmith ran a pre- campaign
that was based on what people knew was a
lie this election was not without
controversy and I'm so proud that London
has today chosen hope over fear and
unity over division
after taking the mayor's office with a
comfortable majority Kahn has brought a
businesslike efficiency to the role
scrapping expensive vanity projects like
the garden bridge and the new route
master buses which cost three hundred
and fifty thousand pounds each the
former lawyer who used to fight the
police in court is now praised for his
close relationship with them I was
talking to a very senior police officer
in the Metropolitan Police who said
there was a sea change when he went into
City Hall and the police were saying how
much they welcome this because they knew
where they stood and it was more
straightforward to work with so he works
like a lawyer he works like a government
minister Kahn's kept his faith at the
fore he's an outspoken voice for
moderate Muslims across the world Donald
J Trump is calling for a total and
complete shutdown of Muslims entering
the United States now by giving the
impression that Islam and the West are
incompatible you're playing into the
hands of the extremists the ongoing spat
between Khan and US president Donald
Trump escalated when Trump went after
Khan was quoting him on Twitter just
hours after the terrorist attacks of
June 30 2017 cons now one of the most
prominent labor politicians in the UK in
fact a recent poll of Londoners found
Khan was more trusted to keep the
country safe from terrorism than the
prime minister or the Labour leader his
story of going from the son of an
immigrant bus driver to the mayor of one
of the greatest cities in the world
plays well with Londoners but can he
appeal to the rest of the nation has
Khan got his eye on the top job and is
the UK ready for a Muslim prime minister
[Music]
you
you